دانييل زاهدي طبيب مبتدا يعمل بمستشفى
بكيمبرج يعاني نقصا مزمنا في الموظفين
زاهديه عملان لمده 60 ساعه تقريبا هذا
الاسبوع وحده باجر متدني اثقله قرض الطالب
من دراسته للطب حيث لا يستطيع السداد
لانخفاض اجره فيما يؤكد انه في ظل الوضع
الحالي لا يمكنه رؤيه نفسه في المهنه على
المدى الطويل على الرغم من حبه لها
راتبي اربعه عشر جنيها استرلينيا في
الساعه ولدي اكثر من 100 الف جنيه من
الديون لقرض الطالب لا اشعر بالتقدير اشعر
انني على حافه الانهاك ولا يمكنني
الاستمرار على هذا المنوال هناك شيء يحتاج
الى تغيير
زميله في المهنه في العاصمه لندن لديه
اكثر من 85 الف جنيه استرليني من ديون قرض
الطالب ويتقاده اجرا بالساعه قدره
19.30 جنيه ويعمل حوالي 48 ساعه في
الاسبوع
العمل اكثر صعوبه هذه الايام في هيئه
الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه
بحسب الجمعيه الطبيه البريطانيه انخفضت
رواتب الاطباء المبتدئين في بريطانيا لعام
بنسبه
26.1 مقارنه بعام 2009 ويرجعون انخفاض
الاجور والتضخم والارهاق وازمه تكلفه
المعيشه الى عده عوامل تدفع الاطباء
للخروج من مهنتهم في وقت تتعامل فيه هيئه
الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه مع قوائم انتظار
المرضى العاليه القياسيه لتلقي العلاج
فيما ستؤدي الاضطرابات القادمه من قبل
الاطباء المبتدئين الى مزيد من الضغط على
خدمه الصحه الوطنيه
المموله من الدوله في بريطانيا والتي
تعاني اساسا من موجات اضراب من قبل
الممرضات وعمال الاسعاف والعاملين الصحيين
الاخرين رش خياط العربيه